And there is the president.
Let's listen in California.
I want to briefly speak about
what's happened
to the Silicon Valley Bank
and signature bank today.
Thanks to the quick action
of my administration over the past
few days,
Americans can have confidence
that the banking system is safe.
Your deposits will be there
when you need them.
Small businesses across the country,
the deposit accounts of these banks
can breathe easier, knowing
they'll be able to pay their workers
and pay their bills.
And their hardworking employees
can breathe easier as well.
Last week,
when we learned
of the problems of the banks
and the impact
they could have on jobs
from small businesses
and the banking system, the overall
I instructed my team
to act quickly to protect these interest.
They've done that. They've done that.
On Friday,
the government regulator in charge,
the FDIC,
took control of
Silicon Valley banks assets,
and over the weekend,
it took control of signature banks
assets.
Treasury Secretary Yellen
and a team of banking
regulators have taken action,
immediate action.
And here are the highlights.
First,
all customers
who had deposits in
these banks can rest assured.
Rest assured, they'll be protected
and they'll have access to their money.
As of today,
that includes small businesses
across the country.
The bank there
and need to make payroll,
pay their bills
and stay open for business.
No losses.
And I know this is an important point.
No losses will be borne by the taxpayer
And we repeat that.
No losses will be borne by the taxpayers.
Instead, the money will come from
the fees
that banks pay into the deposit
insurance fund.
Because of the actions of that,
because of the actions
that our regulators have already taken.
Every American should feel confident
their deposits will be there.
If and when they need them.
Second,
the management of these banks
will be fired
if the bank is taken over by the FDIC.
The people running the bank
should not work there anymore.
Third, investors in the banks
will not be protected.
They knowingly took a risk,
and when the risk didn't
pay off, investors lose their money.
That's how capitalism works.
And fourth,
there are important questions
of how these banks
got into the circumstance
in the first place.
We must get the full accounting
of what happened
and why
those responsible
can be held accountable.
And my administration, no one in my room,
no one is above the law.
And finally,
we must reduce
the risks of this happening again.
During the Obama-Biden
administration, we put in place
a tough requirement on banks
like Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank,
including the Dodd-Frank law,
to make sure that the crisis we saw
in 2008 would not happen again.
Unfortunately,
the last administration rolled back
some of these requirements.
I'm going to ask Congress
and the banking regulators
to strengthen
the rules for banks
to make it less likely
this kind of bank failure
would happen again
and to protect American jobs and
small businesses.
Look, the bottom line is this
Americans can rest assured
that our banking system is safe.
Your deposits are safe.
Let me also assure you,
we will not stop at this.
We'll do whatever is needed
on top of all.
Let's also take a look at moment
to put the situation
in a broader context.
We've made strong economic progress
in the past two years.
We've created
more than 12 million new jobs,
more jobs in two years
than any president has ever created
in a single four year term.
Unemployment is below 4% for 14
straight months.
Take-Home pay for workers is going up,
especially for lower and middle
income workers.
And we've seen record
numbers of people apply
to start new businesses.
More than 10 million of them.
More than 10 million applications
over the last two years.
Starting businesses.
Now we need to keep the program
this progress going.
That's what swift action
that my administration over
the past few years
is all about protecting depositors
protecting the banking system,
protecting the economic gains
we made together for the American people.
Thank you.
God bless you.
And may God protect our troops
in California.
Mr.
President, what do you know right now
about why this happened?
And can you assure Americans
that there won't be a ripple effect?
Well, the president
there was some notable comments.
One, addressing steps already
taken by his administration.
He says Americans can't have confidence
that the banking system is saved.
Your deposits will be there
when you need them.
That a step taken
over the weekend,
that by this morning, depositors
will have access to their funds.
Also notable, Erica,
he says that no losses
will be borne by taxpayers.
This can be covered
by fees
paid into the system
by banks and bank leaders.
The president said will be fired.
Yeah, absolutely.
Let's bring in now
senior White House correspondent M.J.
Lee, CNN business
chief business correspondent
Christine Romans.
So, Christine, starting
let's pick up
because I heard you
as we were both furiously
scribbling notes here
as we were listening to the president.
The fact that he did point out
management will be fired here, saying,
listen, if they were at the helm
when this happened,
they don't deserve to be here now. Yeah.
And they made some big mistakes,
it looks like in hindsight, right,
when they didn't
manage their interest rate risk properly.
This is a company that
took in a lot of money
in deposits
for many, many years
and put those deposits
into long dated treasuries.
And then as interest rates rose
those became less valuable.
And at the same time,
when people started taking the
deposits out
because the tech sector had turned,
then suddenly there was this mismatch
for for this bank.
And as they tried to raise money,
they raised actually alarms
that they were in trouble.
And then you had a run on the bank.
So that management is out.
Christine, I have to ask you,
because this is a first step
and I heard from a lot of folks
this weekend saying
the administration
has to step in now to guarantee all
even uninsured deposits.
Of course,
because the FDIC, FDIC limits
to $250,000.
Many banks,
big, big VC firms,
but also small businesses
have far more money in their accounts.
Biden says we will not stop at this.
We will do whatever is needed.
Notable as well.
What does that mean exactly?
What additional steps?
Was he opening up to, if necessary?
Well, he talked about more regulation
to make sure this doesn't happen again.
And I think that's really important.
We have Dodd-Frank banking reforms
after the last financial crisis
and there had been lobbying and in 2018
a loosening of some of those for banks
just like this one.
So I think there's
going to be a postmortem
look at whether these kinds of banks
should all have better stress
tests tests
and have a higher capital requirements.
So that's a conversation to have.
But this is just
such a unique moment overall.
I mean do you want the federal government
guaranteeing every investment
every bank deposit
and then you're essentially nationalizing
the banks here.
So I think it's important
to note that in normal times $250,000
or less your
your deposits are guaranteed
by the federal government.
In this case,
they're guaranteeing
all of those deposits.
That's a really new moment.
And to get to that point,
the president said
he's going to be asking Congress
to strengthen those rules.
We heard from lawmakers
on both sides of the aisle
weighing in over the weekend.
Is there a plan from the White House?
Is there a plan
even from the president
to speak to lawmakers
and to get a sense of what
that would look like when you're dealing,
of course, with a divided Congress?
Yeah, Erica,
I thought the president accountable
portion of the speech was really notable.
First and foremost, the president
saying straight up
that the managers
at these banks are going to be fired
and that the people
who are responsible for what happen,
they're going to be held accountable now.
We don't know what exactly
that accountability looks like.
And he made clear
that there is going to be
a little bit of time
that is taken to figure out
and get a full
accounting of what
led to these banks failures.
But I think just in the big picture,
yes, the president is
going to be speaking
to members of Congress.
You would expect
that there are going to be
these kinds of conversations
sort of looking back
at the last few years.
Some of the relaxation
of some of these regulations
over the last few years
to try to figure out
what how can we actually prevent
this kind of thing from happening again.
But I think for this morning,
at this moment,
it was very important
for the White House.
Remember, these remarks were added
at the very last minute,
late last night
for the president to get out there.
In front of the cameras
and directly address the American people
and say this lying,
which was key,
he said the banking system is safe.
Your does
your deposits will be there
when you need them.
He really wanted to sort of reassure
the American people,
you know, many of whom
obviously have
recollections going back to the 2008
financial crisis.
That that is not the scenario
that we are about to see that
there's not going to be
some domino effect.
And by the way,
he took a lot of credit
for what he called were
immediate and quick actions
by his administration last night
to prevent that kind of scenario
from happening.
Well, a message to the public
certainly also a message to the markets
that opened in 20 minutes.
Now watching those comments
I'm sure very closely. M.J.
Lee at the White House.
Christine Romans, thanks so much.